arrey I sense from you such like an open
abundance mindset did you always think
like this did you always feel like
things were unlimited that there was no
there was no but a lot of us just think
in terms of a box myself included
it's and I I don't see that from you I
see that that you see endless
possibilities and there's never a
black-and-white answer there's a lot of
grey my world is entirely grey there's
no black and white and it is about
endless possibility it's it's what you
make of it I came to Hollywood wide-eyed
rose colored glass and by the way I'm
still wearing rose-colored glasses I
will be the eternal optimist till the
day I leave this life because it's a
better choice for me but when someone
since noted the thing about moving to LA
to try and get into the film business
they spent years getting known a lot of
those hundreds of thousands of knows and
a very rare instance I might get a yes
but the nose so outweighed it you know
it's interesting there was a book by
Jeff Olson called this the slight edge
and in that book he talks about social
science studies have proven that a child
by the age of five has heard the word no
forty thousand times and he's heard that
same child has heard the word yes by
eight to eight thousand times forty
thousand knows eight thousand yes is
five times the gravity holding that
child down as the buoyant yes up lifting
that child's mindset and sense of
possibility
that's a formative time so they enter
the first grade with with that energy
quite a deficit there imagine the
possibility if that were reversed
how would that kid enter into so into
into into his social a new social
environments but be that as it may I see
the world as endless possibility when
someone says no to me I've heard it so
many times that I've gone deaf
I am literally deaf to the word so to me
when you say no to me I'm smiling and
I'm excited why because it's the same as
he yes I choose it to be the same as a
yes why I know that no is not yes but
what I do know is that the greater
currency whatever you were gonna say yes
to it would have been nice it would have
made me happy but the real win is my
relationship to you with you so if I can
take that no and honor you by saying
fantastic
first of all I've taken all the you know
people don't like to say no it makes
them feel terrible and they feel guilty
that's the mattli but if I take that
away right off the table by going oh my
god great and Surprise them well new new
rules right so I can say that that's
fabulous you know it would you have no
idea the value that you would bring to
my life that you would honor me if you
would be my my three point seven minute
mentor right now my five minute mentor
if you can share with me why this is a
no to you I would be eternally grateful
now you've you've opened the door to
them telling you the truth they're not
gonna say no you've flattered them
you've honored them you've made them
smile hopefully made them laugh and
you're being honest and they know that
we know when someone's being honest with
us and now out comes the thing called
empathy and that thing called caring so
they'll tell you and a you will learn
something important and be that
ineffable thing happens we as two people
have just bonded in an entirely higher
texts I've left the room with an O and a
friend an O and a closer relationship
and a new mentor you do that a hundred
times over the course of a couple of
years success is inevitable because
people who care about you who are more
successful will ensure that that's the
way that's the way it works have you had
a No
then come back a year two three whatever
later and say you know what Gary
remember we talked I was just wondering
I this this is different from when we
last you know and and it kept the
relationship or it kept the meeting in a
good standing there was no negativity
kept it upbeat and then they came back
to you and it turned out there was
something else that they thought of you
for how you approach people determines
how they feel about you
not just in the moment but ongoing I I
have had a lot of people every time come
back with opportunity in a different
form a different time a different place
a different topic a different project if
you will and invite me into a
conversation that was largely the result
of earlier interactions and those
interactions left them with a positive
feeling I didn't make them feel bad I
quite the opposite and
you know that's that that's what success
looks like to me success to me looks
like us a string of pearls human
relationships that were dealt with well
in the moment because now people are
talking about me behind my back but in a
good way or thinking about me
perhaps in a better way and and and then
remembering me because of it and and I
think we all do that we we like we like
to do business with people that we like
that we respect that we trust that we
know how they're going to behave if I
deliver bad news to you and you come
back in a positive way to me I know that
you're the writer I want in a writer
room at 3 a.m. in the morning when
things are really tough and getting ugly
and I can count on you to still be a
human being that does matter you will
always get hired over the slightly more
talented writer if I don't trust that to
be true about them but I do trust that
to be true about you that's how we're
wired
you